half a decade has passed the rubble has
been cleared most of the aid agencies
have gone home Haiti has a
democratically elected
president and the country has a new
slogan Haiti is open for business why do
we say that the country is open for
business because a lot of investors are
looking around the Caribbean to invest
lauron Lamont was appointed prime
minister in 2012 a former
telecommunications CEO Lamont set out to
transform ha's image from a poor a
dependent country to a land of lucrative
opportunities what industry should come
here then if you were to say this is a
business that would thrive in Haiti what
is it manufacturing for
example right now we are one of the top
five t-shirt manufacturing for the
United States I don't know if you knew
that in terms of Tourism attraction we
seeing traction now with large investors
coming in the Marriott hotel is going to
open his
doors the Marriott hotel is being funded
by an Irish billionaire who calls
himself hai's number one salesperson
well we're investing $45 million do we
will probably lose money for the first 6
n months and then we'll turn a
profit so we will get a good return on
investment here no
problem the Marriott is in downtown Port
of Prince right next door to den Brian's
company headquarters digel Haiti's Major
mobile carrier digel operates in 33
countries but Haiti is its largest
market accounting for roughly onethird
of its 12.8 million customers when you
speak to America CEOs and you try to
sell them on Haiti and they say to you
look at the track record it doesn't make
sense that country's got problems right
left and Center how do you sell them I
just tell them my own experience so
we're the largest foreign direct
investor in the country we've had
absolutely no issues setting up our
business no red tape our business has
performed well and it's been a very good
investment so our experience is the
example for everybody
else